>> Tucker: SINCE IT ABSORBED
THOUSANDS OF UNSKILLED
MIGRANTS THAT CAME UP IN THE
CARAVAN, TIJUANA, MEXICO
SHOULD BE ON THE WAY TO BE ONE
OF THE RICHEST SEASONS OR AT
LEAST YOU'D THINK SO BASED ON
WHAT YOU HEAR EVERY DAY.
BUT SURPRISINGLY, PEOPLE IN
TIJUANA ARE UPSET.
WE INTERVIEWED A DELEGATE
LOPEZ, WE TALKED TO HIM THE
OTHER NIGHT WHO SUGGESTED THAT
THE CARAVAN HAS NOT BEEN THAT
GOOD FOR TIJUANA, ITSELF.
>> THEY ARE STILL HERE.
PROBLEMS ARE STILL GOING ON.
THERE HAVE BEEN 280 ARRESTS.
BEFORE IT WAS ONLY FOR DRUG
POSSESSION OR DRUNK IN THE
STREETS.
NOW IT'S FOR BREAKING AND
ENTERING INTO HOMES.
THINGS AREN'T NICE.
THE NEIGHBORHOOD ARE TIRED OF
THEM, MERCHANTS AND THE
SCHOOL.
>> WHAT IS THE MATTER WITH THE
PEOPLE IN MEXICO?
>> THE CALIFORNIA RADIO HOST
IS JOINING US TONIGHT.
>> GOING BACK TO THE TOPIC, I
LIKE IMMIGRANTS AND I GIVE
EVERYONE IN THE CARAVAN THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
MOST DO WANT TO COME FOR A
BETTER LIFE.
THEY ARE MADELY DISMISSED AS
BIGOTS IF THEY DON'T LIKE IT.
BUT NOBODY ON THE LEFT SAYS
ANYTHING ABOUT THE REACTION OF
THE MEXICAN CITIZENS IN
TIJUANA TO THE CARAVAN WHO ARE
SOUNDING LIKE DONALD TRUMP ALL
OF A SUDDEN.
WHY ARE PEOPLE IGNORING THIS?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE
IGNORING IT.
WE IGNORE THE PLIGHT OF THE
HUMAN BEINGS THAT CROSS FROM
ONE OF THE POOREST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD WITH THE 36 YEARS OF
THE CIVIL WAR AND IS THE
COPPED IT -- CONDUIT OF EXPORTIG
DRUGS TO THE UNITED STATES.
ANYTIME YOU STICK PEOPLE IN A
STADIUM AND TELL THEM TO WAIT
THERE FOR AN UNNON-AMOUNT OF
TIME BEFORE THEY ARE --
UNKNOWN AMOUNT OF TIME BEFORE
THEY ARE PROCESSED, YOU'D HAVE
TROUBLE BEING STUCK FOR AN
UNKNOWN PERIOD OF TIME.
WAITING TO SEE WHEN YOUR
FAMILY --
>> Tucker: I BELIEVE THAT.
I PROBABLY WOULDN'T ENGAGE IN
A HOME INVASION IN THAT TIME.
BUT AGAIN WHAT I'M STRUCK BY
EVERYBODY SAYS WE HAVE THE
DEEP SYMPATHY FOR THE
MIGRANTS.
I HAVE SYMPATHY, TOO.
I NEVER HEARD ANYBODY ON THE
LEFT SAY WE HAVE DEEP SYMPATHY
FOR NORMAL PEOPLE TWO WANT TO
PAY TAXES AND SEND THEIR KIDS
TO SCHOOL.
THEIR LIVES ARE BEING
OVERTURNED BY THIS.
THERE IS AN EFFECT OF THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE WHEN NEW
PEOPLE COME.
NOBODY CARES ABOUT THEM AT
ALL.
EVEN IN TIJUANA.
NOBODY CARES ABOUT THEM.
WHY IS THAT?
>> I THINK PEOPLE CARE ABOUT
THEM.
>> Tucker: WHO ARE THE
CHAMPION?
>> THERE ARE SOME PROBLEMS,
ONE -- WAIT.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM OF
GOVERNMENT FAILING.
WE ARE NOT DEALING WITH THE
REFUGEE PROBLEM AND PEOPLE ARE
STUCK WITH THE PROBLEM IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE TIJUANA.
ON TOP OF IT ALL WE HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THE OTHER.
THERE ARE DEEP-SEEDED BIAS.
>> YOU ARE SAYING THE PEOPLE
OF TIJUANA ARE BIGOTS.
BEFORE WE REACH THAT
CONCLUSION IT'S FAIR TO LOOK
AT THE FACTS.
ONE SCHOOL IN TIJUANA IS
CLOSED FOR THREE WEEKS BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T OPEN.
PEOPLE WANT TO SEND THEIR KIDS
TO SCHOOL IN TIJUANA, IN
ANYPLACE.
THERE IS TRASH ALL OVER THE
STREETS.
IT'S SUPER EXPENSIVE AND THERE
HAS BEEN A CRIME SPREE.
ALL I WANT FROM YOU AND
EVERYONE ON THE LEFT IS AN
ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT THERE ARE
REAL CONCERNS, NOT ROOTED IN
THE BIGOTRY BUT ARE RATIONAL
AND FAIR TO BE UPSET ABOUT
THIS.
NO ONE WILL GIVE THE BENEFIT
OF THE DOUBT TO THE NORMAL
PEOPLE.
EVER.
WHY?
>> THERE IS DEFINITELY A RIGHT
TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT TRASH
AND THE INABILITY TO SEND YOUR
KIDS TO SCHOOL AND THE
ENVIRONMENT AND EVERYTHING
ELSE.
>> Tucker: CRIME?
>> BUT AGAIN, YOU HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT --
>> Tucker: UPSET ABOUT
CRIME?
>> YOU SHOULD BE UPSET ABOUT
CRIME.
THAT IS A PROBLEM.
BUT YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT
THE CAUSES ARE AND WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
YOU ARE TAKING PEOPLE WHO HAVE
A PROBLEM OF GETTING FOOD.
67% OF THE PEOPLE OF GUATEMALA
HAVE UNAVAILABILITY TO FOOD.
THEY ARE STILL DEALING WITH
THE CIVIL WAR AND THE FOOD
COUNTRY THAT THE UNITED STATES
SENT DOWN THERE --
>> Tucker: IT WAS TOUGH.
>> WE DID THAT.
SENT BANANA REPUBLIC OUT
THERE.
>> Tucker: AND AGAIN, I SEE
THE SELF-RIGHTEOUS RELIGIOUS
FIGURES SHOWING UP ON THE SIDE
OF THE MIGRANTS.
WHY DON'T PEOPLE ON THE LEFT
GO UP AND SAY WE'LL STAND UP
FOR YOU?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE A
GOOD ANSWER.
IT'S SET UP FOR THE CITIZENS
IN PLACES LIKE TIJUANA OR HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
REFUGEE CRISIS HAPPENING.
ASYLUM CRISIS.
OF THE HUMAN BEINGS AND
CHILDREN.
WE HAD A 7-YEAR-OLD WHO DIED
CROSSING OVER --
>> IT'S TERRIBLE.
TERRIBLE.
>> WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY.
>> I GUESS.
WE ALSO HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO PEOPLE WHO ALREADY LIVE IN
TIJUANA AND LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY FEEL LIKE NO ONE CARES
ABOUT THEM THAT IS WHY THEY
ELECTED DONALD TRUMP.
SOMEONE SHOULD CARE ABOUT THEM
OR ELSE THEY'LL GET MADDER,
DON'T YOU THINK?
>> OF COURSE.
I DO CARE ABOUT MY FELLOW
CITIZENS, TUCKER.
CLEARLY I DO.
BUT THE ISSUE IS AGAIN, YOU
CAN'T JUST KICK PEOPLE TO THE
CURB BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE
THEM BECAUSE THEY ARE REFUGEES
AND WE VIEW PEOPLE OF
DIFFERENT SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS
WITH A BIAS, IMPLICIT BIAS.
TAKE HARVARD, A TEST FROM THE